Let me go next to our friend Maddie from Evanston,
Illinois.
Maddie, what's what's going on with you?
What's on your mind today?
And you.
You are on.
Maddie, you can go ahead, I see you've unmuted,
but we can't hear you might be an issue of
microphone selection.
All right, Maddy, just we'll give you one
more opportunity.
There you are, Mounty.
Oh, awesome.
Hi, David.
I first love you so much for all that you
do.
You're giving me such a reality check right
now, and I really appreciate that.
Good.
Second of all, I know after watching last
night's debate, I couldn't help but wonder
how in the hell the right is like framing
this and like how they could possibly think
that, like, Trump might have won the debate.
Like, I'm trying to get into that mindset.
I, like, simply can't.
And I'm wondering if you could give me any
more insight into that.
So basically, there's two sets of people that
are defending Trump.
There's people saying that Trump actually
won because Biden stuttered.
Right.
So there's that group that's basically just
saying that, you know, Trump just won.
There are people and an earlier caller identified
it who are conceding or C, implicitly conceding
that Trump didn't do so well and he was unhinged
in this.
But they're essentially blaming Chris Wallace
and saying Chris Wallace was part of like
a fake news media cabal to give Trump the
tough questions and to challenge Trump more
and that it was all rigged against Donald
Trump.
Those are the main two lines of defense.
Now for me, they both ring hollow.
But the point is, all that really matters
is what the independents thought and both.
I don't know if you're listening to something
else in the background or that if that's my
own voice feeding back, but maybe we could
do something about it any better.
Now, that is better.
Yeah.
All right.
Yeah, I mean, that's crazy.
But but helpful to frame it that way.
And I guess my other question is like, how
do I restore my faith in this democratic process
when, you know, the leadership is telling
me that, like, you know, if it goes the way
that he doesn't wanted to go, then we're all
screwed and anarchy will reign, etc..
So in in the immediate 30, it's horrifying.
In the immediate 30, however many days we
have left in the immediate 30 or however many
days we have left, what we have to do is just
overwhelm the vote and try to get the biggest
victory possible.
If and when we do that, then we can talk about
fixing these other systemic issues which have
been exposed, including that our checks and
balances really only work if somebody enforces
them.
And what we've learned under Donald Trump
is if nobody enforces them, they don't really
do much for us.
Yeah.
Will that matter?
It sounds like you've got a lot going on there,
so I'm going to let you go.
But I really appreciate you talking to Mary.
Thanks so much.
Take care.
All right.
There's Maddie.
Maddie having a very, very busy day there.
OK, guys.
A success the first day taking calls on discord.
The call quality was stunning.
And I really appreciate everybody who got
in touch.
We will do it again next week.